[Music]
for many americans the uncertain outcome
of the presidential election is adding
to the anxiety
of an already stressful year according
to a survey by the associated press
about six in ten of the nation's voters
feel this country is on the wrong track
our lead national correspondent that's
david begna spoke with americans
who are on edge as this process plays
out david good morning to you a lot of
people are relating to this
good morning my friend here we are in
times square live this morning and i'm
thinking back to yesterday when we
listened
a lot did a lot of listening to about a
dozen people gail when you talk to the
biden supporters
they're nervous stomach and knots on
eggshells checking their phone watching
the television
but when you speak to the trump
supporters it is clear they knew exactly
what they were voting for
they believe he's going to win and they
specifically voted because they wanted
four more years of trump the anxiety
in america right now is spilling out
into the streets watch
from new york to chicago to las vegas
protesters on both sides of the
political divide took to the streets
wednesday
some people are angered by president
trump's declaration that he already had
the votes to win
before all the votes had even been
counted the concern is that
donald trump may seek to interfere in
the vote count
meanwhile in detroit dozens of trump
supporters protested outside of a vote
counting center
shortly before michigan was declared a
win for joe biden
and in the battleground state of
pennsylvania which is also still
counting mail-in and provisional ballots
voters say the tension there is intense
i am
absolutely in a state
of high anxiety i've never seen a
president act this way
21 year old zion moronga is from
pennsylvania
i met him at the sussex sit-in and chat
diner
in nearby new jersey what's your anxiety
level
yeah i'm definitely a bit anxious just
because in past elections it hasn't
taken this long and hadn't been
like all this like suspense so that's a
bit like
jarring i guess not everyone i met was
as concerned like 80 year old trump
supporter louis post
how anxious are you feeling right now
about the results i feel good
i feel good i think he's going to get in
but lewis's wife carol was worried about
claims of widespread voter fraud
the ballots have been thrown away
they've been
you know they've been thrown away they
found ballots all over the place
but that's not true there hasn't been no
widespread ballot throwing away
that's what i heard that's what you
heard right and where where are you
hearing that
i heard that from the president you
heard it from the president
yeah and you believe what he says uh
i'd like to believe what he says he's
our president
do you always believe what he says i'd
rather not say
so you believe the president when he
says that mail and ballots have been
thrown away but you chose to vote male
invalid
yeah because because of the virus
miss post said listen she believes the
virus is real that's why she wears a
mask
she did not want to tell us who she
voted for she says there's a big divide
in her family
and she didn't want to get herself in
any trouble tony
we are a united states of uh anxiety at
the moment david and
it includes for our industry we're
trying to get things right here
for people like uh mrs post there david
what are you doing
to uh maintain your level of calm
so listen i jokingly said on social
media yesterday i hadn't showered in 24
hours because i've been stuck to the
phone or the camera
so uh people were like what are you
talking about get in the shower boy
uh yeah look walking on eggshells i'm
i'm stuck to the news i'm a news nerd
uh i'm nervous but i'm ready to get past
this too yeah a long a long hot shower
is good for everybody and putting your
phone down as well david thank you very
much
brother i say ditto to what david bagno
said but you know why this is so hard
guys
because we already said going in we
weren't going to know that night yes
it was going to take a minute or two to
get the results in
but when you hear claims of fraud